Now we're ready to argue for the
equivalence of our random access model
and the traditional Turing machine.
To translate between the symbol
representation of the Turing machine and
the numbers of RAM,
we use a one-to-one correspondence, E.
Note that E of the blank symbol is 0.
That way, the uninitialized parts of
the tape correspond to uninitialized
parts of RAM.
First, we argue that RAM can simulate
a single tape Turing machine.
The role of the tape played
in the Turing machine
will be played by the memory.
We'll keep track of the head position
in a fixed register say, R1 and
the program and the program counter
will implement the transition function.
Here I've written out in pseudocode
what this might look like for
the simple Turing
machine shown over here,
which just replaces all the ones
with zeroes and then halts.
Being in state q0 corresponds to
having the program counterpoint here.
So the RAM will execute a sequence of
tests for what the symbol under the head
would be and it adjusts the values
of the tape and memory accordingly.
Sometimes, just moving to the right by
changing the value in this register and
then saying, hey,
let's return to state q0.
Or sometimes, a write is necessary,
say, for this transition, here.
And then again, we need to
move the head to the right and
then transition back to state q0.
And sometimes we need
to move to a new state,
like when we encounter the blank
symbol and then in q accept we halt.
Now we argue the other way,
that a traditional Turing
machine can simulate a RAM.
Actually, we'll create a multi-tape
machine to implement a RAM
since that's a little
easier to conceptualize.
Of course, anything that can be
done on a multi-tape machine
can be done with a single
tape as we've already seen.
We will have one tape per register and
each tape will represent the numbers
stored in the corresponding registers.
We also have another tape that's
useful for scratch work in some of
the instructions, the one's that
involve constants like add 55,
then we have two tapes corresponding
to the random access device.
One is just for input and
output and the other is for
simulating the contents of
the memory device during execution.
Storing the contents of the random
device is the more interesting part.
This is done just by concatenating
the index value pairs using
some standard syntax,
like parentheses and commas.
The program of the RAM must be simulated
by the state transitions of the Turing
machine.
This can be accomplished by having
a subroutine or sub-Turing machine for
each instruction in the program.
The most interesting of these
instructions are the ones
involving memory.
We simulate those by searching the tape
that stores the contents of the RAM for
one of these pairs that has
the proper index and then reading or
writing the value as appropriate.
If no such pair is found, then the value
in the memory device must be zero and
we can write a new pair if
it's a writing structure.
After the work of
the instruction is completed,
the effect of incrementing the program
counter is achieved by transitioning
to the state corresponding to
the start of the next instruction.
That is unless the instruction
was a jump in which case,
that transition is affected.
Once the halt instruction is executed,
the contents of the tape simulated in
random access device are copied
out on to the I/O tape.